my name is Luis kaneshiro I build
courses here at Udacity and I've used
version control in different forms for
about 4 years now
version control makes me more of a
risk-taker in the sense that I'm able to
explore pretty significant changes in
the code base architecture differences
at a very low level without fear of
breaking the entire project and and
freaking out you know for lack of a
better word to try to make it work again
and so without version control the way I
looked at code was as soon as it was
working I would make very small
iterative changes whereas with version
control I'm able to rethink the entire
code base or or rethink parts of them
that quite honestly I wouldn't have
approached or even touched for fear of
breaking it so in general big picture
the things I really like about version
control is really this idea of
exploration without version control I
feel that developing as a programmer is
is taking little baby steps of making a
program incrementally better whereas
with version control you you can explore
such a large space of things to try and
you can do that easily without really
worrying about having to go back and fix
a project that's that's broken so I feel
version control has made me a better
programmer because it allows me to
explore deep concepts the architectural
concepts within programs that I wouldn't
be able to explore easily and more
efficiently if I was not using fergus
tree control